all right um so I'm gonna uh call to
order the meeting of the house uh
Judiciary Committee for a work session
and we'll Begin by I'm going to ask
representative cutoff if she lead us in
the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the pledge of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
um
nine bills that are on that we retained
during the uh
during the course of the uh of the
session
and what I'd like to do is I want to
make this a relatively informal uh
meeting what I'd like to do is is get is
solicit information from the committee
as to uh what bills people have some
interest in working on
um and and maybe to try to see if
if it appears that
um
you know there's a basis for us for us
sort of having a different view of the
bills than we had originally or that
there's some basis for people coming
together to on various types of
compromises if that's possible and I
hope I hope it is
um
so what I'd like to do first
is take
um
two bills that I think are they have
they have they're different in in what
the what they cover but they have
um they are related in the sense that
they both deal with privacy issues
and that is SB 255
and SB and house bill 314.
um and what I'm what I'm I'm throwing
this out for everyone's consideration
what I'm thinking is if we have people
that are interested in working on those
and I and I would include myself as one
who is working who is interested
if we would if there would be a way
that we might combine those bills
um to you know to have a more
comprehensive because 255 is basically
um deals with uh imposing uh privacy
rights
establishing privacy rights for
individuals related to information that
is that is in the possession of for lack
of a better term sort of larger
businesses
314 is dealing with providing
privacy rights for information that may
originate in the private sector but ends
up in the hands of government and it's
the Privacy versus the government
um so maybe
um it would be possible to uh
to combine those in some way
and so
um
I I would be interested in working on
that and I representative Devine also
are there other people that have some
interest in
I'm sorry oh wait a minute so all right
all right so I'm sorry so um we have
Lynn Divine Smith tur who else
yeah
I think so yeah I think that I think
they
um
all right other uh Joe Alexander okay
all right
um
sure let me start so it's Lynn Divine
so um and I'm going to ask I'm gonna
call on the ranking member to correct me
if I if I've uh if I misstate anything
here but as I understand it
um if we if we have a subcommittee
um we need to we need to give notice
that we're going to have a if when we're
going to have a uh a meeting
um and we can't do it in July and August
so if we're going to do anything we have
to do it we have to do something
in June if there's to the extent that we
have time to do that and then more
likely
um in uh in September
um the other the other question I have
because I'd like to do this if I can uh
uh
representative Smith is can we appoint
somebody that's not a member of this
committee to work on it um another rep I
um no my understanding is that this is
these are bills that are before this
committee and this is a sub we would be
forming a subcommittee of this committee
we of course can invite anyone we choose
other members or people from the public
to come and participate in the
subcommittee work sessions okay of
course they can't vote but um they can
participate I would suggest that you
might want to appoint a chair of the
subcommittee no I I agree whenever you
want yeah no no that's a great idea so
what I'd like to say is I I know
representative Earth has a great
interest in this area and I I think he
would be a you know uh he's here now and
he would have a great deal of of
valuable input to make so even if he
can't sort of formally be a member of
the subcommittee I think we want to make
sure that he is you know is notified of
the meeting so he can come and that that
kind of thing I think you would have
important input
um so
um
does somebody want to volunteer to be
the chair of the subcommittee I'm more
than happy to do it but if somebody
wants to volunteer like representative
Smith I'd be happy to appoint you as the
all right
um
anything else people want to talk about
on the um with regard to those two bills
did
um the the only thing I would say on
this and obviously we we you know will
have more much more detailed discussion
on this
um
the
one thing that I notice as a substantial
difference between 255 and 314 which
you know I
whether we can bridge this Gap or not I
don't I don't know but it would be
interesting to I mean it would certainly
be worth a try is one of the big things
that
um I think was was an issue in in in 255
being retained is there are some people
that believe it it does not call call
for a private cause of action right now
and some people believed it should
um I was one of those personally that
that feel pretty strongly there should
not be a private right of action but
um
that's neither here nor there for now
but the the important thing I was going
to say is 314 does call for some kind of
a private right of action
um as I recall and so that you know if
there if we're going to combine this
that that is something that um is going
to be
we're going to have to work that out how
how we deal with that uh and I don't
know whether it can be worked out but
it's I think it's these are important
enough things that um
we should uh
we should try
anyone else yes
Mr chair I also want to make sure that
everyone on the committee knows that
um although they haven't been named to
the subcommittee they are all
welcome to show up and participate in
the work sessions and they will be work
sessions rather than hearings
um and uh but then at some point the
subcommittee would vote and bring that
recommendation to the full committee no
that's that sounds fine
um and you know what what just one other
thing I um I I thought I specifically
asked the clerk about this while we
cannot have while these subcommittees
cannot have any meetings
um in in July or August if somebody you
know if there's a if somebody thinks
that wants to take a stab at putting
together a draft of some of some
proposed way that we might that these
might that and you when you're working
on your own that's fine you can do that
on your own it's just we can't we can't
have a discussion about that the
subcommittee can't have a discussion or
a meeting about that until until uh
September but there's nothing to prevent
you know people if you have some time
over the summer you want to put pen to
paper uh that's great
um all right anything else on 255 or
314.
all right seeing none
um
the next bill I'd like to turn to is HB
this is a bill that requires agencies to
provide periodic updates of when records
will uh if uh if a municipality or
someone else some other agency subject
to the right to no law
is unable to provide uh a response to a
request within the usual time which I
think is five days then they're required
to provide
updates of when the records will be
provided and
I gotta to be honest with you I think I
have to say I'm having a senior moment
here because I'm not quite sure I
remember exactly why what the issue was
that we retained it but we did and so
um
people have an interest in working on
this and uh
sure
so when we talked about this bill the
Ombudsman was just starting up it's my
understanding I'm wondering if they had
any
is there anyone here from uh that knows
anything about in the audience I mean
that knows anything about them
Mr chair I think that
we retained it because we were waiting
on kind of maybe a report to see if this
bill is even necessary with the with the
Ombudsman just like like okay okay
um
so I
I think it might be wise to reach out
and see kind of get a report from the
Ombudsman and see how many of these
cases that they've settled or
um adjudicated I guess is the word
um
regarding like the timeline on right to
know requests and making sure that if if
this isn't being dealt with by the
Ombudsman that we deal with it with this
film all right
um so yes representation and again goes
this is the first time this committee
has handled uh the retained bills I also
want to point out that
um uh we are um
at least at the moment still in a
society where we're free to decide
things for ourselves that might change
but right now that's what it is and uh
it might be that no one on the committee
wants to invest extra time on any of
these bills in that case what would
happen is we would not be forming a
subcommittee
since no one should be compelled to
serve on the subcommittee but when the
full committee gets together later you
know probably in October
um then the full committee would would
discuss uh
those bills since since there wouldn't
be a subcommittee coming in to make a
recommendation so I just want to point
that out as I did not see people
jumping up to volunteer right right so
you know I wonder if it to sort of um
follow up on what both you uh and
representative Alexander said would it
make sense to just say
um we're not going to do anything on
this one until October and in the
meantime I'll reach out to the Ombudsman
and find out how how things have sort of
gone and if there's if there's if we
need to take some further action we can
you know we can do it in October Mr
chair yes
oh yes representative trip
uh since since we are combining 255 and
314 together into one subcommittee I was
wondering uh since we have we have
another bill no set of bills that deal
with right to know and that would be 149
the one that we're discussing right now
and uh 652.
you know uh if we're going to you know
use the logic that uh like bills could
be you know looked at at the same time
uh I I would suggest we combine these
two bills together and have the
subcommittee look at them you know
jointly
and I would be happy to serve on that
committee okay
um what are people think I I you know I
I mean I I'm wondering if these two I
they it's true that they both deal with
the right to know law but they're oh
they are different they are you know I
think different in a way that maybe 255
and 314 are not and so I'm just
wondering if the
um if that what do people think about
combining it is it yes thank you Mr
chair I think that um
149 is not germane to the other two
bills 314 and 255. so it doesn't sound
like a good idea I think the scope of
the two privacy bills HB 314 and SB 255
are very very
I think it would be difficult so it'll
Jam everything together in a soup yeah
you know representative De Lorenzo
unless I I may have misunderstood a
representative Tripp but I think he was
suggesting a committee that would
combine HB 149 with HB 652 which we
haven't yet discussed
so um but but I guess even I even there
I'm not sure that those are kind of
close enough that it would make sense
but what what do people think
uh representative they're both
um they both um title HP 652 is uh
mildly well not really misleading but
91a is basically the right to know and
open meetings law so HP 652 deals with
more of an open meetings issue than a
right to know or you know document
retrieval issues so that's a little bit
different I mean it's not a terrible
idea having the same subcommittee deal
with both of them but it's even though
it's the same RSA it's two fairly
different functions of the same RSA so
they are something that is
on now that is perhaps not being
followed you know it's a five day thing
now and it's not being followed whereas
I perceive
sick perhaps not being found 652 as a
whole new entity so I think they're too
far apart I think I truly feel that if
we find from the Ombudsman that this is
not an issue uh the 149
perhaps we don't need it or do we need
to be preventative in having it so that
it doesn't I know it does happen but I
don't know if it happens enough to reach
people going to the odd budget so
I think they're two different and
representative Smith this was your bill
right and I just wondered how strongly
you feel about 149 do you feel it can be
solved with finding out what the
so I may your response
um I think the suggestion that we wait a
bit
um makes a lot of sense and I don't
notice that representative De Lorenzo is
objecting to that we always
um can decide subsequently that we do
want to have a subcommittee
um and we can do that in September or
October right so you know what what
maybe what if we do this
um why don't we
um
my inclination is that 652 may be
something that people have some interest
in working on I I frankly would would
have some interest in that but why don't
we why don't we do this when we get to
652 if we if we appoint a subcommittee
for that
that subcommittee can work and then uh I
will make the inquiries of the Ombudsman
uh and then in October if if you know if
it decides that we if we decide that we
need to do something on uh 149 either
the whole this whole committee uh can do
that or we might we might then task that
the 652 subcommittee with dealing with
this also or form another or form
another Circle yeah one of the so that
makes sense to everybody
all right all right
um and since we started to talk about
652 why don't I turn to that one next
um
and I guess
I'd start out by saying my inclination
on 652 I think I may have mentioned this
to uh representative Smith was when I um
when this first came up I uh really was
my inclination was that it we didn't
really This was
um you know a solution in search of a
problem and that really that we didn't
really need to do anything but as I
heard more at the hearing
um I I guess I my my view changed on
that that um
that maybe there really is something
that we need to deal with here and I
note that um there was a supreme New
Hampshire Supreme Court decision that
was referenced during the hearing and I
I haven't read it recently but I did
really read it right after the hearing
and there was a
a pretty strong separate opinion by
Justice Hans Marconi
um which sort of said
you know though even though I mean her
view was even the law as it is now there
she would have interpreted to say that
there needed to be some kind of notice
or something like that so
um uh that kind of reinforced my view
that maybe there is something that that
could be worked on here and so I would
be willing to work on a subcommittee if
other people did anybody else have an
interest in that representative trip
um
representative Perez how about somebody
the Rd Isle yes
that representative yes I'm interested
okay okay all right good so got drafted
yes
be informal so
um
I think this works both ways I know
there's something in court right now
about a
people who are mentioned in
letters
not being able to get
that letter
say if you wrote a letter against me
and I wanted that letter to see that
letter it's some places are withholding
that even with a right to know so it has
gone to court it is in court
so I think it works both ways it also
could work towards that
helping that as well am I making sense
uh because people because if I have a
letter against me and you won't share it
with me you just say oh so and so said
you're blah blah blah
I should have a right to get that letter
and I think people are
not allowing that to happen with the
right to know and I think this could
help that as well
okay that might be the case I mean one
of the big
issue that that I was still left with on
652 is
the
how you know the way it
the way the statute now is worded if if
this is going to be there's a there's a
there's a right of to have a meeting uh
not public if there's going to be if
you're going to be talking about someone
that in a way that might adversely
affect the person's reputation and the
pro and and the proposal was if that's
the case then you ought to give notice
to that person right and the problem I
have is
that's awfully broad I mean I tried I
think maybe after hearing talk about you
know what if the person that you're
going to be talking adversely about
lives and lives in Singapore do you you
know do you have to give notice to that
person
um or or what you know if it does it
make a difference whether the person
that you're going to be talking about is
a citizen of the of the jurisdiction
that's going to be having the discussion
uh as as opposed to not
um I I I I'm I guess I'm just worried
about sort of unintended consequences
that um of of of of uh
imposing the notice but maybe there's a
way that we can you know that we can
narrow that in a in a to that would make
sense to everybody so
um
isn't that a good example of why we need
a subcommittee to talk about these
things and just work it out and we
certainly never want to interfere with
anyone's right to travel right right
that's very true so I so I right now I
have uh Lynn Tripp Perez and Delorenzo
um anyone else have an interest in
working on that subcommittee and uh does
somebody want to volunteer to be the
I'll volunteer
I'll be the chair
all right there we go there you go and
representative De Lorenzo will be the
all right
um
so
I have a question yeah since uh these
are subcommittee meetings I I assume
there's some requirement for record
keeping the minutes or something is that
correct uh yeah yeah right so uh would
would we need a secretary or uh would
there be a a researcher which would be
present during these meetings that could
do that I think the researchers um are
already overworked and we won't
have them assume the responsibility that
should be held by someone on the
committee but it's since you don't need
to know in advance I would suggest when
the first meeting of the subcommittee is
called and people have rested and
recuperated over the summer
um somebody will likely be willing to
step up and say they would serve as
Clerk of the subcommittee I don't think
that's needs to happen now all that
needs to happen is there has to be
someone authorized to call the first
meeting and we're doing that by naming
the chairs right
all right
um
um the next uh is 283 House Bill 283
this is the bill that limits rental
application fees to 35 or the cost of
the background check whichever is less
and then there's some other
um all other I think if I'm
if I've summarized correctly I think the
language of the original Bill said all
other fees charge as a part of the
application process must be refundable
um
anybody have an interest in working on
that
yes Charles yeah
me as well Mr chair all right
um uh Alexander and Delorenzo
um
all right
oh whoops I'm sorry uh representative
Morgan you want to serve on that also
I'm sure why not all right or again
trip
um
man
um I I'm comfortable doing it if that's
all right um
uh all right uh House Bill 641 LED
inspections
oh all right I'm sorry yeah no if we
could do 360. that's fine um
yeah no I had it in a different order
that's fine
362. this is the bill that eliminates
the right of um
that the proposal was that the this bill
would eliminate the right of a defendant
to remove cases from the Human Rights
Commission
after the Human Rights Commission finds
probable cause
if I'm wrong I please anyway anybody on
the committee correct me I think one of
our concerns on this was we um
thought that there might be broader
issues with the Human Rights Commission
in terms of um of the timeliness of
of its work product and stuff like that
and I think that among other things was
what
um was what sort of led to it being
retained so
um do people have an interest in working
on this
representative Manos
D Lorenzo I I believe that all the
issues um
around
the Human Rights Commission are being
taken care of and I think it would make
sense to
test the bill
it's straight it's clear-cut and it's
the building speaker
well I'm I'm sorry representative kuta
respectfully I I'd love to join it I
think
I appreciate all the work that was done
I'm just very concerned
that the number of cases that are being
to be frank it seemed like the the
committee was dysfunctional like it
wasn't completing cases I mean the
number that had been completed per year
was so low and it seems like this is
just putting a Band-Aid onto it and I do
very much appreciate the work that was
done and I and I mean no disrespect I
just think we need to do a little bit of
a deeper dive to see why it's taking so
long to complete these cases having
somebody pull them out is one thing but
if they're just not able to complete the
cases that's not servicing anybody so we
need to figure out either how to get
them to service the cases or if the
model just isn't working
maybe the cases need to be moved to a
court and we need to be funding the cost
of it being completed in court but but
to have a commission that
cases are just sitting you know in a
black hole and nobody's getting any
findings it just doesn't seem right you
know that for anybody involved
yes representative D Lorenzo uh thank
you Mr chair
um addressing um
representative kotob's concerns um there
an audit a performance audit by the LBA
and that will be this year it could be
could have even started
um additionally
um the governor
um authorized spending for another
um worker in the Human Rights Commission
office so that's why I feel that things
are being taken care of all right thank
you fine so you know what the the one I
guess what I one of the things that um
that I think is an issue here is that um
the
main argument As I understood it of the
people who wanted who Advocate the
change that was proposing the bill was
it's on it's unfair the way the way the
law works right now
a claimant
has mud is required to file a claimant
who claims that they were uh that they
were discriminated against in violation
of the Human Rights Act has to go to the
Human Rights Commission with the
complaint in the first instance
and then is not allowed to remove the
matter for I believe it's 180 days
um at the 180 day point they can remove
if they want to but they don't have to
the plan the claimant doesn't have to
the way the law works right now
once the Human Rights Commission
by uh makes a finding of probable cause
and as I recall
that was one of the big problems is that
it took an inordinate amount of
sometimes years for the for the Human
Rights Commission to make a finding of
probable cause which is hard to
understand but
but the the argument was that under the
laws now written once the Human Rights
Commission makes a finding of probable
cause the the defendant is then allowed
to remove the case to Superior Court and
the argument and I think it was a good a
valid argument by the by the CL by the
plaintiff's bar for lack of a better
term was that's unfair to have a
plaintiff be have be required to wait
all this time for the Human Rights
Commission to make a determination and
then allow the the defendant to set to
remove the case at that point I I
thought that was a was a compelling
argument but the the to me the answer to
that is not to eliminate the defendant's
right to remove at all rather I had
proposed an amendment uh that would have
said
let's change the law to say this the
plaintiff we'll leave the law the way it
is for for in this regard the plaintiff
has to go to the Human Rights Commission
first and cannot remove the case from
the Human Rights Commission for for 180
days
but let's change the law to say once
that 180 day period has been has expired
now the clock starts to run on the
defendant the defendant will have 60
days after that 180 days to either
remove the case to the superior court or
if if the defendant doesn't then the
defendant is barred from from doing it
at all that eliminates the art the the
the complaint that the you know the
defendant is just sort of sitting on
their hands and letting lots and lots of
time go by and then uh and then removing
the case the defendant would be required
to do it right away
or or not remove it at all and so I mean
I'm not saying that's the only solution
and and I'm not saying that the that you
know we shouldn't consider the the the
the terms of the original bill but I do
have a real problem with the idea of of
completely eliminating the defendant's
right to remove
um particularly
given what seems to be
the time problem
um with the uh with the Human Rights
Commission so I I guess I that's a long
way of saying I think that something
does need to be worked on here and I'm
glad that uh representative
uh
I think
and uh Manos and representative
dilorenzo do you have some interest in
working on this also
Delorenzo anyone else that's interested
okay uh hang on
Andrus
Oregon
who else
anyone else
all right
who would like to be chair
all right representative cuta
and representative Manos would you like
to be Vice chair
all right got it
all right
um
so next
is uh house bill 396.
um
so let here's here's my impression on
396 and if I'm if I'm
my sense is that we are
so far apart on this that I I mean
is there any chance that we're going to
be able to come to an agreement on this
I'm just kind of wondering I mean my
sense is that no that we're gonna we're
gonna have a 10-10 vote uh
uh in November when we have to vote and
that that's you know that's the way the
recommendation will go to the floor in
next January but there's
is there I mean do people have a Mr
chair I can't predict
um what would happen I can tell you that
although representative Macbeth is not
uh able to be with us today she has
indicated to me that if there were to be
a subcommittee she would like to serve
on that so I just want to okay mention
um well do I just did anybody else have
an interest in serving
foreign
thank you
if if you're if you're required to come
up with a committee I'd like to serve on
it but I will say that it's the only one
who voted against us on the on the
Republican side uh because I it was
something that obviously needed more
work
and it I took an awful lot of heat for
that uh and and so if you're going to do
it again I'd like to sit on the
committee but I do not support the bill
okay all right
um so
so representative uh Macbeth you said
was something if the group decides to
have
yes representative I'd like to serve on
the committee and I think we need to
re-look at the bill
um there's a lot that's happened in New
Hampshire since this bill came up
uh that
um
has come to the Forefront so I I think
that um perhaps
being well informed and and
understanding the bill Moore May sway
people one way or the other for or
against it so I really feel that in in
light of what's going on we really need
to readdress this all right so I have
Perez
Andrus
Macbeth
and uh
testerman
who just who else did you just say yeah
um uh Perez Andrus Macbeth testerman and
uh
foreign
okay
um who wants to be
uh five yep who wants to be um chair of
that
ly
I'm sure of that I'm sure of that too
um
all right
let's make with that ice chip
sure that's fine not here exactly that's
just
we have a volunteer for cheer uh that's
been known to happen
so let's see all right
um so next is um
let me summarize what my understanding
is and people correct me if I'm wrong
original this the original bill here was
designed to have to give the Department
of Education
the ability to file
uh and prosecute for lack prosecutes
probably the wrong word but but I'm
gonna use it anyway uh the ability to
file and prosecute
um
complaints of a civil nature obviously
not criminal but uh prosecute uh
complaints alleging violation of the
Human Rights Act in arising in from in
the educational con educational setting
of a school or whatever
uh that the Department of Education
would be able to
itself prosecute those cases before the
Human Rights Commission
um
that as I understand it would have made
the Department of Education the only
agency other than the the attorney
general that would have the ability to
directly prosecute cases before the
Human Rights Commission
and
um I think a number of us not not
everyone for sure but a number of us
including myself had questions about why
we should make why there should be this
special exception for the Department of
Education
um as a result I I think of maybe for a
number of reasons but as a result of
partially I think of of
this some of the skepticism that was
expressed by the committee
um the Department of Education has
um
either has or is in the process of
working out an arrangement with the
Department with the Department of
Justice the Attorney General's office
about
how
they will work together so that if
there's a if the Department of Education
believes that something there's
something that uh should be prosecuted
so to speak before the Human Rights
Commission
um
they can work with the Attorney
General's office and eventually the
Attorney General's office would make a
decision as to whether they would do
that so
that
the main part of the bill my sense is
is there's no need for us to take any
further action on the main part of the
bill right now now
having said that I the the
what came up next in that was the the
um there was a suggestion by the
Department of Education that an
amendment to the bill should be drafted
which I agreed with and I drafted the
amendment to give the Department of
Education subpoena power
really in a different context The
subpoena power was just was designed to
give the Department of Education
subpoena power
so that they so that it could subpoena
records
in cases in which the Department of
Education would itself be holding
hearings dealing with for example uh
allegations that that Educators had
violated the the code of conduct for
lack of a better term for educators
we had a hearing on that
um and as I recall the emotion on that I
made a motion to approve that it failed
on a 10 to 10 vote
um
so
having spoken to the clerk my
understanding is that
that
if this bill dies
there would be nothing to prevent
someone and and I have to say it
probably would be me introducing the the
substance of the amendment as a new bill
next year and I probably would would do
something like that maybe with some
changes but in other words there'd be
nothing
uh preventing uh the introduction of a
bill uh dealing with the subpoena power
issue so
um
that is that would be kind of my
inclination is to do is to not do
anything with the main Bill and then
next year I'll introduce that Amendment
or something like that and there were
some people uh some people during the
hearing on the amendment had raised
issues about whether there would be
whether there should be some changes to
the text of of my legislation and I'm
perfectly open Perfectly you know open
to those kind of suggestions but that
would so my suggestion would be not to
do anything with the main bill
representative Smith
oh thank you
um I understand
uh and appreciate what you said but by
the very nature of you saying it
um I think you serve to remind all of us
that there were disparate views within
this committee on that bill and it it
didn't necessarily come down in any
traditional way as to why people felt
one thing or the other and if there are
people willing to participate
um
I think that
uh
I think it might be helpful for us to
have a subcommittee to take a look at it
take a look at your Amendment took a
look at the underlying language and that
other factors that have actually come to
pass since we looked at this earlier in
the spring oh no well well I know I'm
happy to hear that I mean my my sense
and I've been and if to the extent that
I've been misreading this my sense
from the discussion at the hearing on
there was a group that that the the
people at on on one side of the aisle
for lack of a better term didn't want to
have the Department of Education have
subpoena power
period and so if that's if that's not
the case then I'm then that's great I'm
I'm I'm I'm very happy to have a
subcommittee on this
uh representative I volunteered for
enough subcommittees I'm on two already
and I was playing to be on zero but so
it's in common with this one which was
um
and we saw this in a debate on the bill
that went through education we debated
if
a couple of weeks ago which is um
it doesn't take in the entire uh
Universe of publicly funded education I
guess the schools or school districts
which I guess does at least take in
charge of public schools as well as
conventional Public Schools but still
leaves out
the non-public Academy such as Pinkerton
or Co Brown it doesn't take in uh out of
state
uh public schools that were tuitioning
students into
and it also doesn't take in uh the
providers and the
EFA program amongst others so like it's
uh the pillows introduced is also like
uh incomplete because it doesn't empower
the Department of Education to intercede
in on behalf of all uh you know
of all
um
families who are using uh publicly
funded education but I think I mean I
think
I think my presence on the subcommittee
is unnecessary and I think the whole
bill is unnecessary but I just thought
that's that's just a flaw in the
original bill which uh I guess actually
your Amendment does kind of uh at least
implicitly uh bypass but so that's just
my comment on it all right so uh yes
it's not working oh geez
just talk loudly I'll speak I'll just uh
if there is a subcommittee then I would
I would I would volunteer well
representation if you seem to think that
it would be worthwhile and I'm that's
fine
who else wants to okay
all right so we have so we've got uh
Paige Smith
um I'm sorry dude Lorenzo uh no I'm
sorry Lance sorry about that lonza
um we need another at least one
that sound so we've got five people who
top page Smith lonza and Tripp
if you want to be chair you can beat you
okay
all right all right uh so you know what
I think this dealt more with
um
people having access
to
um
putting things before the Human Rights
Commission and more than subpoena I
think this had to deal with one of the
big things that came up and
hearing from parents that
make complaints they can't
afford
to follow through on complaints
whereas if the Department of Education
was helping them with that or filing for
them
um I just had a guy from a parent this
morning who had filed a complaint
cost her seven thousand dollars to file
a complaint
um it was for special ed
um
young parents can't afford that that's
one of the things that I think they were
looking for in this in in I may be wrong
but I think that's one of the things if
the doe can file complaints
against human rights or against
what people are doing they need someone
to be able to do that because they
cannot afford to do it so that's just a
comment right I I I mean I I guess the
uh As I understood the original bill it
I don't think it dealt with special
education as I thought it was like a
claim of discriminate if somebody was
claiming discrimination in violation of
the Human Rights Act
um
maybe I mean maybe it is Broad enough to
to Encompass that but I guess the thing
the thing that was never clear to me is
why isn't why should the Department of
Education
have
a special ability to prosecute cases
before the Human Rights Commission
whereas for example suppose that suppose
that there's a claim that um
that in something dealing with the
transportation department that somebody
has been
um somebody had somebody in the
transportation department has violated
the Human Rights Act
um the transportation department can't
prosecute the case before the Human
Rights Commission they have to go to the
attorney general and so why should the
Department of Education be treated any
differently that's
I think it came up very clear from um
attorney Diana Fenton saying that we're
dealing with children having the right
to be educated and their parents having
a right to speak for them and I think
that was one of the things
that came up because they don't have
someone representing them the doe
basically because children have a right
to be educated the doe is representing
the children and the parents
okay I'm I'm still not clear why why the
why the Department of Justice wouldn't
be in a position to do that but anyway I
um but you know what I you know what I
guess I would uh I'm sorry
representative
I I was thinking that um
I'm trying to figure out how a public
school
could go before human rights
um
when we have
when they
Human Rights Commission has bigger fish
to fry
um in protecting people under protected
classes
um so in a public school isn't a public
class
or a protective class
right but I guess as I understood it I
mean I I guess the the the
quintessential case that I thought
was
um
that I that I thought this the original
bill would deal with would be a
situation like this suppose that there's
a claim
that a teacher in a public school
discriminated on the basis of race or
sex or whatever the you know whatever
other protected class against the
student
um that the
the original bill would purport to allow
the Department of Education
to bring a to prosecute an action in
behalf of that student before the Human
Rights Commission and
the
the problem that that I had and I think
I think some other people on the
committee shared it is
under the current law in that situation
that I gave as an example
the Department of Justice could
prosecute that case before the Human
Rights Commission and so
why isn't that good enough
um there's no I don't you know it's I I
do remember there being some
suggestion that
um
the Department of Justice wasn't
taking those cases but it really sort of
seemed to me was that
what was really being what was really
happening is there may have been a
disagreement between the Department of
Justice and the Department of Education
as to whether some particular case was
worth it was worth Prosecuting
um
I spent enough time as a prosecutor to
know that there were a lot of times when
the FBI or the DEA or the police really
thought somebody should be prosecuted
and the the prosecutor didn't and so in
that you know the prosecutor decides and
that's just the way
um that's sort of the way it goes um but
anyway the one other comment I wanted to
make and I'm wondering if this
subcommittee could at least think about
my
my sense is
that any
any agency that has the authority to
take
some kind of disciplinary action whether
it's the Department of Education or the
transfer whatever whatever the agency is
if an agency has the authority to
conduct hearings and take disciplinary
action that agency ought to have
subpoena power it shouldn't be I mean I
know it can be the it can be the
Department of Transportation or the Fish
and Game Commission or whatever it is if
they have the authority to conduct
investigations and conduct and hold
hearings and take some action against
somebody they ought to have the power to
issue subpoenas
um there you know that that doesn't
subpoena's uh that doesn't mean that
they can go out you know that we're
going to give them all guns and they can
go out and and execute search warrants
but it does mean that they can issue a
subpoena
it should mean that they can issue a
subpoena and if somebody gets a subpoena
and thinks that there's not a valid
basis for the subpoena being issued they
can go to court just to quash The
subpoena that's the way it yeah I think
it should work for all agencies so I
what I'm suggesting is maybe this
subcommittee
ought to think about whether it would
make sense with under whatever
conditions the the subcommittee thinks
might be appropriate to to more
generally say that agencies that have
that kind of authority should have
subpoena power that's that's my
suggestion
yes
thank you Mr chair
um I'm kind of recalling right or wrong
that
there's a Complaint Form or process for
um
students and parents to file with the
school or Department of Education
don't know if that's correct or not but
I thought I I heard that in some
testimony
and and if there is online or Complaint
Form or a process within the school or
Department of Education
then
they must certainly be able to do
something with that including
investigate or maybe refer
depending upon the seriousness of the
case and the particulars of it
breaking away from that thought for a
moment did you say that the Department
of Education is working with the Human
Rights Commission to develop some kind
of cooperation on this matter no I'm
sorry I was saying that with regards to
the the subject of the original bill
the proposal to give the Department of
Education kind of the direct authority
to prosecute cases before the Human
their their my understanding was is that
the Department of Education was working
with the Department of Justice
to uh to prepare some kind of a
memorandum of understanding
uh not that would give
the Department of Education the
authority to actually undertake those
prosecutions but a process whereby
they would consult with each other and
and the Department of Justice would then
make a you know a more informed decision
about what cases they they that that is
the Department of Justice would
prosecute involving educational alleged
educational discrimination and does that
work that way now uh as a practical
matter in some way well
I I I I I I
think it the answer is it should but I
think that was part of the problem that
the education was was frustrated with
that they they believe that
it was not working well that the
relationship between
education the Department of Education
and the Department of Justice was not
working as smoothly as it should have
and they were trying to
work something out to uh to make it work
more smoothly and I thought and my
understanding was that they had actually
made some they they made some progress
on in fact it may it may be that by now
they actually have a memorandum I'm
saying I don't know that but um maybe
they do so education takes complaints
but then they did end some way or they
go fallow is that
they're not being for well executed to
I I think it I mean that that may be
true in some cases I think that may that
might be true yes uh uh representative
Perez and then representative Morgan
I just got this from a parent
um last night at 6 35. it was a
complaint that was made to the
Department of Education it involved her
special ed child
um and she had to get a lawyer to do
this correctly which is a cost to a
parent the biggest problem it's my
understanding that the Department of
Education has not having subpoena power
is if they go to the SAU and say we need
the record of
this you know how many hours of this did
the child blah blah blah
they're having trouble getting it
because they do not have subpoena power
that this ruling
States in it that they were unable to
get some of the information that they
were looking for so I think that's the
problem and I think that's what they
said when they came and talked about it
is they don't always they don't always
have access what
to what they need to make an informed
decision so I think the process works
but the subpoena power is necessary so
that they can
do their job representative Horgan
yes I think I'm worried this might
create a conflict of interest for the
Department of Education since they also
uh work you know they also like work to
support the schools in the school
district so they're um
so I'm not sure where they're having an
adversarial so they're sort of like a
strange situation if they're advocating
on behalf of a parent against the school
although it is certainly
the core function of the primary
education to make sure that the schools
and the school districts and so forth
are doing their jobs effectively and
correctly so like you know there's uh
they do have a vested interest in making
sure that these schools provide the
right services that the children but I'm
not sure if they're intervening on
behalf of the parents in the lawsuit
directly like that that seems to place a
lot of their that seems to create a
conflict of interest situation where
they've divided loyalties there even
though
even though on the other hand they're
both sides want the children to get the
best the appropriate education so I
think
I think there's like a bit of a
conundrum there if we were to pass at
least this bill is introduced so
representative Smith thank you um this
conversation is very interesting and I
would suggest that it would be most
appropriate to have it take place before
the subcommittee as the subcommittee
members struggle with trying to figure
that sounds like a good that sounds like
a very good suggestion anybody else have
anything else they want to say on 533
all right so the committee will be
chaired by representative Smith Vice
chair will be representative koutab the
other members are representative page
representative Lanza representative
Tripp
all right
um
41. okay
I I and I know that representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair
um so
originally we had retained this with
hopes of working on it
um I
I right now don't see a need to work on
I haven't seen like an overwhelming
communication regarding this bill
um from the sponsor or other
um lead inspectors that are that seem
aggrieved with the current law so I'm
okay just holding on to it and if there
is a dire need in September we could
deal with it but I don't think we need
to
I I couldn't agree more I could I
couldn't agree more this I as I think I
said at the time I never this seemed to
me to be a a solution in search of a
problem that easily could be solved by
the lead inspectors by just getting a
getting part part of all of their fee up
front if they were worried about getting
paid then right so anyway I anybody have
a problem with if we don't take any
I'm sorry Mr we will take action we will
take action in the full form right yeah
um in the fullness of time right right
right
question about where you meet do you
have to meet here yes yes
um you have to meet here you have to uh
it has to be in the calendar right right
so you have to and remember that
um the calendar will be every other week
for a while I don't remember exactly
when it will start to be every week but
if you're the chair you have to make
sure that you notify Karen who will
um do everything that's necessary to get
into the calendar and also to have
assigned a room for where we would be
meeting right you know what Paul did
mention to me though apparently for
subcommittees only 12 hours notice is is
uh is is good enough I'm not saying we
shouldn't give you know you obviously
should try to give as much as possible
but I think I I don't know my my
um My Philosophy would be
um
the more the more heads that come
together on these complex issues the
better and therefore I always like to
give as much notice as possible
um and uh
yeah no I don't disagree with that I'm
just saying just I think that just so
you know what the apparently the rule is
that you only have to give 12 hours but
but I agree with you completely it would
be it'd be better to give as much notice
as possible
um
anything else I think we've covered all
the bills anything else that we need to
talk about now
um yeah oh well yes yes
um did someone else have their hand up
no okay then um this is probably the
last time this committee will meet in
full
um until uh
the weather warms up a little bit
um and I want to take this opportunity
to thank the chair
um on the overwhelming majority of bills
that have come before this committee we
have
um Universal
agreement and we can see that in the
votes that have gone to the Full House
in the small number of bills where there
is not Universal agreement those bills
by definition are the bills that are
most
um
contentious and also where people's
views are most deeply held
and for the entire session I believe
this committee has been conducted under
the chairs leadership
recognizing that
it doesn't cost a thing to be civil
and that respect and civility
um can take place no matter how deeply
we oppose each other on any particular
bills and that
that
um climate has come from the chairs
leadership and I would imagine that I am
not alone that in fact everyone on the
committee would join me in thanking you
for your leadership
well thanks
thank you all very much I I very much
appreciate that representative Smith and
members of the committee and I think
this has been a really great committee
it's been a pleasure to work with all of
you I've learned a great deal from from
all of you and I think our debates have
been I think our discussions and debates
have been you know the way they should
be representative Stapleton
we didn't talk about 641 or did we and I
missed it
well no we did that's that's the lead
inspection it was like a ship in the
um
right right
um so anyway uh I yes I would like to
thank you for your summaries after um
our executive committee meetings um
hearings they've been great oh well
thank well thank you
and I will I'm going to put something
together on you know as a result of what
we did today too just so everybody I
wasn't trying to remind you no no no no
I but I'm I'm glad it's I think it's
good to have you know it's good to have
something in writing so you're something
you can refer back to uh yes
representative Perez
and I'd like kudos to Caitlyn because oh
yes
absolutely absolutely I mean not only
being a newbie but taking on this big
responsibility that's that's you've done
a terrific job there's no question about
that and then then it's I mean
especially when we've got a full day of
hearings that can be keeping everything
on track is it can be very difficult and
you've done a terrific job in that
um
all right well uh anything else we need
interesting
yes and thank thank you for to both of
you for all of your work during the
during the session
um it's been it's been terrific we
really appreciate it and I'm and I'm
going to thank Karen also when I before
as I'm leaving she's she's been terrific
also
um all right
um
and if any other things we need to talk
yes I'd like to uh thank Marjorie um you
know um also of course with the guidance
of her throughout the year as well as of
course yourself but
um being a newbie
um it's been great um I could have not
accomplished what I've done this year
without without her guidance so thank
you all right I want to second that
because I don't think I could have
either without her guidance that's for
sure
no I I I I it's very much true because I
um this I'm I'm I'm only a two-term
representative so I there's a lot that I
uh that I didn't know and you have been
terrific in in uh educating me and I
yeah what do I do now right exactly all
right uh anything further all right well
thank you everyone uh see you tomorrow
and I hope everyone has a great summer
foreign